The last thing I want to talk about before we move on to our next potential source of error
is quantifying how much this angular error affected our measurement
or our calculated circumference as a percentage.
We know that if there's no angular error,
our circumference that we calculate is 46,250 kilometers.
We already did that. That's the calculation that Eratosthenes made.
What about when there's error involved?
Well, we've made these 2 calculations as well.
And I just want you to tell me percentage-wise how much different is this number
from 46,250 and likewise for this one.
You can enter your answers here and just round to 1 decimal place.